what do you think
girls you really
you can't be touching her no he wasn't
touching her you weren't she just got
here
that's kim kardashian's daughter chicago
west and niece dream kardashian blaming
shy's big sis north for their elf on the
shelf getting sick
it's really cute yeah kim posted the
snaps on her instagram story tuesday it
all started when the 41 year old reality
star was informed the family's elf on
the shelf was under the weather what's
happening
it's sick why is it sick because it fell
down itself
it fell down
i feel like you were in some of those
decorations what do you think
girls you really
you can't be touching her
no he wasn't touching her you weren't
she just got here
north did it
north was touching her looks like the
elf on the shelf mysteriously fell from
her hiding spot because chicago and
dream still claim they are innocent sick
[ __ ]
but she put her sleeve she holded her
sleeve with the elf so she never really
touched her
i think that the elf needs to be in the
doctor's office like this i don't
nor
i don't think this is a good
we cannot touch these elves guys
we didn't touch it
yeah instead the girls point fingers at
chicago's siblings eight-year-old sister
north and two-year-old brother psalm
west zombie touched it so we're gonna
blame everyone else zombie touched it
and then it fell down north saves the
day with magic explaining to her little
sis and cousin that they need to
sprinkle quote just a pinch of magic
dust it's magic this is magic sprinkle
it on it guys it takes a little bit with
your finger oh
but kim's kids aren't the only ones
getting in on the holiday spirit her
sister kourtney kardashian's ex scott
disick is also getting festive
celebrating hanukkah with his and
court's three kids here's mason penelope
and rayne on scott's instagram story
lighting a menorah scott's caption
family first in another snap rain looks
shocked in the best way as he opens one
of his gifts as scott puts it he was
quote a happy little fella so i figured
this would be the move to make as for
how courtney is celebrating the holiday
season i'm just like living life and
whatever happens happens well she's
prepping to walk down the aisle the 42
year old reality star got engaged to her
fiance blink 182 drummer travis barker
in october and it seems they've already
got wedding planning in motion just last
month travis and courtney attended
friend simon huck's wedding to fill
rippertella courtney posted pics from
the event and travis was quick to
comment quote our turn next i love it
shortly after travis popped the question
a source told et that the newly engaged
couple has already started talking about
planning their big day explaining quote
lately they have been considering having
a destination wedding that will be
intimate and small they are hoping to
get married sooner than later it's safe
to say the kardashian family has a lot
to be thankful for this year